[Musique]
il y a tout juste 50 ans la France
gagnait sa place de troisième puissance
spatiale après l'URSS et les États-Unis
elle parvient à son tour à placer
Astérix son propre satellite en orbite
nous sommes le 26 novembre 1965 avec ses
fusées des premières véroniques à la
famille Ariane la France a su se
démarquer et démontrer également sa
puissance scientifique et industrielle
[Musique]
mais la France et l'espace c'est aussi
des hommes et des femmes qui ont dépassé
les frontières de l'atmosphère terrestre
comme s'il voulait justifier de
l'importance d'une présence physique
dans l'infini de ce 8e continent le jour
où la France a voulu aller dans l'espace
et ben on était là pour y aller on l'a
fait on la rempli mission
9 français ont déjà séjourné dans
l'espace au cours des 17 missions
réalisées avec les Russes et les
Américains
nous sommes la troisième puissance en
nombre de vols habités je suis persuadé
qu'on a tous contribué à porter notre
French Touch et le dixième astronaute
français Thomas Pesquet est attendu
prochainement à bord de la Station
spatiale internationale
j'ai eu beaucoup d'admiration beaucoup
de simplicité beaucoup d'humilité c'est
ça aussi un astronaute ses explorateurs
ont défricher des chemins que nous
emprunterons certainement tous un jour
l'exploration c'est ça on ouvre ce
terrain là pour ensuite les gens
puissent l'utiliser tous ensemble on va
aller de plus en plus loin le but ultime
c'est d'aller vers Mars et l'aventure
spatiale ne fait que commencer
qui sont ces 10 astronautes français
quelles ont été leur mission qu'elle
voit ont-ils ouverts pour l'humanité
[Musique]
découvrez l’étonnante épopée de ces
Français qui ont conquis l'espace
[Musique]
l'histoire de l'homme dans l'espace
démarre au début des années 60 dans un
contexte de guerre froide
URSS et États-Unis ce livre un rapport
de force dans une course technologique
et freinée le 12 avril 1961 les
Soviétiques envoient le premier homme
dans l'espace Youri Gagarine réalise un
tour complet de la terre à 250 km
d'altitude son vol va durer une heure et
48 minutes
les Américains quant à eux démontrent
leur supériorité le 21 juillet 1969 jour
où Neil Armstrong pose le pied sur la
Lune
la France même si dans ces années a
développé ses propres fusées qui a fait
d'elle la troisième puissance spatiale
du monde n'a ni la volonté politique
d'abord ni la technologie suffisante
pour suivre le chemin engagé par les
deux superpuissances pourtant les succès
des programmes spatiaux français et la
volonté d'indépendance insufflée par le
général de Gaulle ont posé les
conditions favorables à une coopération
fructueuse non seulement avec les
États-Unis mais surtout avec l'Union
soviétique
culture
science progrès voilà dans quel but
peut-être sceller l'alliance nouvelle de
la Russie et de la France
dès cet instant-là il y avait eu
quelques quelques fuites on parlait déjà
d'un Français éventuellement dans
l'espace chez les Soviétiques Jean-Loup
Chrétien est le premier Français à être
parti dans l'espace jeune pilote de
chasse de l'armée de l'air il voulait
déjà voler encore plus haut ses
camarades le surnommait d'ailleurs le
cosmonaute
à l'époque on était en train de monter
en puissance à travers l'Europe et à
travers le monde pour rentrer dans
l'arène des spécialistes de l'espace je
crois que ça devait être logique que le
plan politique de dire pour être
crédible dans cette nouvelle compétence
spatiale il faut avoir des choses mais
ça va pas traîner parce que c'est
quelques années plus tard que ça cette
officialisé
et cette rumeur se confirme
effectivement très en plus tard en 1979
lorsque les Soviétiques qui ont
développé un programme de station
spatiale propose à la France de
constituer un équipage commun c'est la
première fois qu'un pays non communiste
va pouvoir voler avec l'URSS parmi les
cinq candidats astronautes retenus par
l'agence spatiale française le CNES au
milieu de 400 postulants seulement deux
vont pouvoir partir accomplir cette
mission en Union soviétique
le moment le plus grandiose ça a été
quand le CNES il nous a dit ça y est
nous avons fait notre choix ce seront
messieurs chrétiens et Monsieur Baudry
qui partiront l'Union soviétique pour
commencer cette entraînement
Patrick Baudry et le deuxième français à
être parti dans l'espace il souhaiterait
aujourd'hui que l'homme puisse dépasser
leur [__] basse terrestre des stations
spatiales afin de conquérir de nouveaux
territoires
la sélection certainement la phase la
plus dure la plus ingrate de la route
pour aller dans l'espace et donc quand
vous en êtes là déjà c'est tout va mieux
Jean-Loup Chrétien et Patrick Baudry
s'apprêtent alors à intégrer le corps
des cosmonautes en URSS c'est comme cela
qu'on appelle les hommes qui volent avec
les Soviétiques côté américain on parle
d'astronautes mais avec cette première
sélection de français le terme
spationaute va également voir le jour
ce terme on l'a inventé avec Jean-Loup
pendant la sélection c'est marrant un
terme français puisqu'on est français
quand même et la première conférence de
presse quand le CNES a présenté ces deux
candidats aux médias on nous a dit
interdiction d'utiliser ce terme il
n'est pas correct il mélange une racine
latine et une racine grecque donc on a
pu utiliser et quand on est revenu en
France tout le monde utilisait le terme
spationaute
nous sommes en 1980 Jean-Loup Chrétien
et Patrick Baudry s'installent à la Cité
des étoiles près de Moscou le centre
soviétique de préparation des vols
spatiaux habités pour apprendre à
devenir cosmonaute
côté non suivi tout était secret
Jean-Loup et Patrick ils étaient très
peu accessibles par les équipes
françaises qui préparait la mission
Lionel Suchet entre CNES en 1989 dans le
domaine des vols habités auxquels ils
consacre les 15 premières années de sa
carrière son parcours la mené depuis à
la direction du Centre spatial de
Toulouse donc ça c'était un moment
particulier vraiment le moment du
défrichage on a appris on a essuyé les
plâtres on a on connaissait peu de
choses à ce moment-là cette erreur le
temps des pionniers la cité les étoiles
à l'époque c'était pas une cage on n'en
sortait comme on voulait mais c'était un
cocon doré avec
des restrictions des arrangements pour
faire en sorte que qu'on en sorte que le
week-end on était on était vraiment en
pension toute la semaine mais il nous
épuisé tellement pendant la journée que
le soir on avait qu'une envie c'était de
dîner de regarder un bout de film puis
d'aller se coucher on n'a jamais eu le
sentiment
d'être dans un milieu hostile jamais au
contraire on est entré à la liste des
étoiles comme on entre dans une famille
qui vous adopte
les deux Français poursuivent leur
entraînement en URSS dans un contexte
international des plus tendus en ce
début des années 80 les Jeux olympiques
d'été de Moscou sont boycotés par une
cinquantaine de nations celle-ci
manifeste leur opposition à l'Union
soviétique qui vient d'envahir
l'Afghanistan et déclencher une guerre
qui va durer 10 ans
et c'est dans cette incertitude
politique de leur avenir à la Cité des
étoiles que les deux Français
poursuivent malgré tout leur préparation
dans de bonnes conditions mais dans une
ambiance très scolaire imposée par les
équipes soviétiques
en fait il voulait qu'on rentre et qu'on
puisse montrer qu'on n'avait pas perdu
notre nom il s'était mis en tête de nous
apprendre beaucoup de choses y compris
le russe de temps en temps nous on aime
ici pour aller dans l'espace donc ça
c'était monotone et quelquefois
un peu envie de dormir à certains
gourmets comme on était que deux ça se
voyait tout de suite il y en avait un
qui dormait
50% de la population ça se voyait tout
de suite
un sol d'entre eux pour apprendre le
départ de cette mission avec deux autres
soviétiques
et ce sera Jean-Loup Chrétien
Patrick Baudry lui est assigné à
l'équipage doublure
Jean-Loup et mon année de 8 ans il est
colonel je suis commandant
même si c'est pas le sujet tout ça
s'intervient bien sûr donc il y a pas de
raison que je vois avant lui si lui est
en capacité de voler mais là encore il y
a une ambiance une atmosphère qui fait
que c'est avant tout un groupe qui fait
que tout ça passe très bien et vous
arrivez à Baïkonour la veille au soir du
lancement où il y a un dernier qui
rassemblement entre les deux équipages à
base de vodka ou là bon ben voilà vous
êtes heureux que l'autre parte
ce qui était dur pour Patrick c'est que
personne ne parlait d'un autre vol après
et que les pays frères avant nous ils
avaient tous fait un vol puis terminé on
se dit il va peut-être se fouler la
cheville en jouant au tennis ou de ça
peut arriver n'importe qui mais c'est la
seule chose qui va pouvoir inverser le
le rôle
le 24 juin 1982 après deux ans de
formation intensive Jean-Loup Chrétien
prend la direction du pas de tir de
Baïkonour et s'installe au sommet de la
fusée à l'intérieur de laquelle se
trouve le petit vaisseau spatial russe
Soyouz
Soyouz toujours en service aujourd'hui
est un système utilisé depuis 1967 pour
desservir différentes stations en orbite
autour de la Terre sa technologie n'a
pratiquement pas évolué témoin de sa
robustesse et de son extrême fiabilité
pour envoyer des hommes dans l'espace et
surtout pour parvenir à les faire
revenir sur terre
à 43 ans Jean-Loup Chrétien devient le
premier français à partir dans l'espace
lors de la mission PVH pour premier vol
habité il passe deux jours à bord de
Soyouz avant d'arriver à sa destination
la station spatiale salute7 après de 250
km de la Terre
le rôle à bord et celui d'un ingénieur
navigant chercheur et un peu cobaye
aussi par moment on avait toute une
armada d'expérience scientifique donc il
y avait des expériences médicales des
expériences technologiques et des
expériences astronomie son 7 jours
intenses passés avec une équipe de cinq
personnes au total
pour réaliser des expériences
scientifiques et ce qu'il faut dire
d'abord c'est qu'on fait en
micropesanteur dans une station spatiale
qui est un véritable laboratoire
scientifique des expériences
scientifiques de grande qualité
dans les années 80 il y avait une
demande très forte de la part des
opérationnels de l'espace de mieux
comprendre le comportement humain en
impesanteur son adaptation comment on
pouvait mieux sélectionner et mieux
entraîner les gens sur terre avant de
les envoyer là-haut et comment on
pouvait mieux les entraîner une fois
là-haut pour qu'il sera adapte aux
conditions terrestres d'une manière plus
convenable
ce premier vol spatial avec un français
est une réussite Jean-Loup Chrétien est
accueilli triomphalement par son
compatriote Patrick Baudry
[Musique]
formidable le retour c'est plus
impressionnant que le départ
une réception est donnée à la Cité des
étoiles Jean-Loup Chrétien il reçoit la
plus haute distinction de l'URSS il est
fait Héros de l'Union soviétique alors
retour en France les deux amis seront
reçus quelques jours plus tard par le
président François Mitterrand qui le
remettra la Légion d'Honneur
Jean-Loup Chrétien inscrit son nom dans
l'histoire de la conquête spatiale
française et il poursuit le rêve d'avoir
la chance de voler une seconde fois un
murmure entendu par les plus hautes
autorités soviétiques qui deux ans plus
tard lui ont à nouveau ouvert les portes
de la Cité des étoiles Jean-Loup
Chrétien suit un nouvel entraînement
dans le cadre de la mission haragas il
se prépare cette fois pour rejoindre la
toute jeune station spatiale Mir
qui en russe signifie monde et l’étape
suivante des stations s'ajoutent il
s'agit cette fois d'une station spatiale
composée pour la première fois de
plusieurs modules mir a servi de
laboratoire de recherche spatiale ces
dimensions ont permis à l'homme de
réaliser de nombreuses missions longue
durée avec une présence humaine
ininterrompue pendant près de 10 ans
Jean-Loup Chrétien décolle à nouveau
nous sommes le 26 novembre 1988
il est donc c'était heureux et fier de
la mère qui m'est fait d'être pour la
deuxième fois le représentant de la
France au sein d'un équipage
franco-soviétique
[Musique]
à cette époque l'assemblage de la
station Mir n'en est cassé tout début la
mission Aragats va durer près d'un mois
[Musique]
autant un vol le 7 jours chaque jour du
matin jusqu'au soir est un rime très
soutenu par le programme où on veut
profiter au maximum de ce qu'on peut
faire en une journée là il y a
l'organisation d'une vie à longue durée
et le mois s'est passé très très vite
comme un mois de vacances on n'a pas
envie de pouvoir se terminer au cours de
cette mission Jean-Loup Chrétien va
réaliser malgré lui avec un compagnon
russe la plus longue sortie dans
l'espace pour l'époque
dans le vide spatial les deux hommes se
retrouvent arnacher à la station
orbitant à la vitesse de 28000 km heure
le tout dans une apparente légèreté
les sorties extra véhiculaires sont des
expériences souvent racontées comme
étant des plus magiques avec la terre
qui défile sous vos pieds mais réservé à
quelques rares privilégiés
une sortie extraculaire c'est vraiment
un moment particulier parce que ça
représente des risques spécifiques parce
que c'est encore un environnement encore
plus agressif que l'intérieur de la
station donc ça nécessite beaucoup de
préparation et puis tout ça pour que ça
se passe jamais comme prévu
et le danger va se confirmer les deux
cosmonautes ne parviennent pas à
déployer une structure complexe destinée
à accueillir une antenne pour la station
Mir
la sortie extravéculaire va s'éterniser
près de 6 heures au lieu des 3 heures
initialement prévues
donc on était au bout de l'autonomie de
nos systèmes on a eu quelques petits
problèmes donc le problème de
déploiement de l'antenne ensuite un
problème moi de ventilation de mon
scaphand qui a fait que petit à petit
bon scaphandre c'est obscurci c'est
couvert d'une grosse couche d'eau sur la
visière donc qui m'empêchait de bien
voir et une fois rentrer dans le sas qui
est petit et où il y a très peu de
lumière je devais fermer la porte les
coutilles du sas et ne voyant rien à
travers ma visière
ça a été un miracle qu'on soit rentré
pour le raconter et pour la petite
histoire les deux astronautes sont
finalement parvenus à déployer la
structure en donnant des coups de pied
dedans durant les six heures de leur
sortie spatiale ils ont réalisé quatre
fois le tour de la planète
la troisième et dernière mission de
Jean-Loup Chrétien se fera en 1997 aux
États-Unis cette fois
mais le premier vol d'un Français à bord
de la navette spatiale américaine sera
réalisé dès 1985 par Patrick Baudry
la navette américaine est un système
plus complexe que le vaisseau Soyouz et
surtout réutilisable elle pouvait
accueillir de deux à 8 personnes avec
des missions très variées grâce à une
vaste soute elle permettait de placer
des satellites en orbite de rejoindre
des stations spatiales et servait aussi
de laboratoires scientifiques autonomes
dans l'espace
tout comme le premier vol de Jean-Loup
Chrétien la place dans l'espace de
Patrick Baudry et le résultat de
tractations politiques elle a été
négociée deux ans plus tôt en 1983
contre un accord d'atterrissage de
navettes militaire américaine en
Polynésie française
Patrick Baudry par Houston s'entraîner à
la NASA dans le corps des astronautes
américains
l'entraînement c'est avant tout du
travail technique scientifique et
également un entraînement physique qui
permet dans la meilleure forme possible
ainsi que l'aspect psychologique
l'assemblage des équipages
l'environnement etc qui était très bien
fait chez soviétique alors que chez les
Américains l'aspect psychologique était
complètement
évacué n'existait pas d'un autre côté je
considère que rien la motivation est là
la psychologie elle suit
Patrick Baudry est d'abord prévu sur une
première mission qui subit de nombreux
problèmes techniques et finit même
paraître annulés une situation qui
révèle la crainte pour toute astronaute
de ne jamais partir
on se dit toujours je veux rater mon
tour
je dirais que la noblesse du métier
d'astronaute à cette époque en tous les
cas surtout quand on était français
c'est à dire russe ni américain c'était
qu'on était jamais sûr de d'aller dans
l'espace on était jamais sûr de partir
donc c'était l'incertitude tout le temps
sur le plan politique sur le plan
technique finalement quand ça part on
est heureux ça c'est clair que quand ça
s'allume c'est le bonheur absolu
le vol de Patrick Baudry s'arrache du
sol le 17 juin 1985 pour une durée d'une
semaine à bord de la navette Discovery
c'est la mission STS 51g
dans l'équipage lors de 51g ma mission
était un groupe d'expériences
scientifiques sous l'égide du CNES et
élaboré par des scientifiques français
le plus souvent coopération avec des
Russes ou des Américains mais par des
laboratoires français
ce qui était passionnant c'est justement
d'avoir une méthode de travail
soviétique russe et américaine en suite
et elles sont très différentes je les
Américains c'est extrêmement rigide
c'est la procédure la procédure la
procédure à bord de Discovery on a
emmené 300 kg de carnet de check-list
documentation 300 kg à bord du Soyouz on
avait chacun un kilo de sang de
check-list
des avantages indéniables coffret la
navette américaine contrairement au
Soyouz était sans nul doute le délai
très court dans lequel les astronautes
pouvaient démarrer leurs expériences
on pouvait travailler pratiquement 1h30
après avoir décollé du pas de tir 39 un
cap Canaveral or avec les Soviétiques à
l'époque on pouvait commencer à
travailler que 48 heures après le
lancement
48 heures c'était en effet le temps
nécessaire au vaisseau Soyouz pour
rejoindre la station spatiale dans
laquelle les équipages allaient pouvoir
ensuite réaliser leur mission
pour cela Soyouz doit d'abord se placer
sur la bonne orbite se rapprocher
progressivement de la station pour enfin
s'y arriver une procédure qui a depuis
été ramenée à 24 heures
Jean-Loup Chrétien Patrick Baudry ont
résolument marqué le temps des pionniers
ce sont les gagarines Français
et avec eux la coopération en matière de
vol habité c'est normalisée avec les
Soviétiques et les Américains qui ont
continué d'offrir quelques places à la
France à bord de leurs moyens d'accès à
l'espace
ils ont influencé et influencent encore
plusieurs générations d'astronautes
Jean-Loup quand je le voyais c'était
vraiment un respect et c'est toujours
comme ça d'ailleurs pour ce qu'il a fait
je veux dire si j'arrive à faire ce
qu'il fait ce sera ce sera super
Jean-François clervois et le cinquième
français à être parti dans l'espace pour
lui être astronaute c'est avant tout
rêver d'espace il souhaite ouvrir la
voie à l'humanité
Jean-Loup reste pour moi le celui que je
regardais comme le guide et côté Patrick
Baudry je venais tout juste d'être
sélectionné astronaute quand on m'a
proposé de faire partie de la cellule
qui suivait en continu sa mission le
fait qu'il ait vécu en Russie
et aux États-Unis et qu'il était assez
récemment qualifié pilote d'essai je
pense qu'il y avait quelque chose à nous
apporter les jeunes
le profil de pilote de l'armée de l'air
qui ont été Jean-Loup Chrétien et
Patrick Baudry va perdurer encore
quelques années et sera d'ailleurs assez
représentatifs des Français dans
l'espace qui vont leur succéder lors de
nouvelles missions que ce soit avec les
Russes ou les Américains
c'est un profil qui est typique de toute
nation qui se lancent dans les vols
habités et qui ne sachant pas qui trop
sélectionné va chercher d'abord le
profil qui se rapproche au plus près de
ce qu'on imagine être le métier
d'astronaute
s'il faut aller se mettre dans des
conditions qu'on a qu'on a jamais
rencontré que ça va être difficile il
faut des gens des profils oui militaires
pourquoi pas si on veut faire de la
recherche pendant 6 mois dans la station
avec beaucoup de réparation du bricolage
de la science un peu d'improvisation il
faut des gens qui sont plus
scientifiques plus plus créateur on va
dire nous on est plus fait pour pour
travailler dans une équipe intégrée et
puis dans le futur ça va continuer ça va
continuer ça va changer on va envoyer
des gens j'espère quelque part un peu
moins peut-être technique et militaire
mais après Jean-Loup Chrétien et Patrick
Baudry il est encore trop tôt et c'est
donc à nouveau un militaire Michel
Tonini pilote de chasse pilote d'essai
également qui est sélectionné par la
France pour embarquer avec les Russes
après avoir fait partie de l'équipage
doublure sur le deuxième vol de
Jean-Loup Chrétien Michel Tonini quitte
la terre le 27 juillet 1992 pour sa
propre mission cette fois
Antarès direction mir sous la
bienveillance de Jean-Loup Chrétien
[Musique]
son vol va durer 13 jours son programme
est basé sur des expériences physiques
physiologiques et des tests sur des
composants dans l'espace
alors on voudrait vous dire bon courage
bien entendu ils s'en devient que ça
vous vendent pas et surtout réussite
dans ce travail collectif
à vos compagnons ce voyage que ils sont
aussi dans notre pensée et que nous
réjouissons de cette collaboration
entendue
là on a eu des relations tout à fait
différentes à la fois avec nos
partenaires russes et puis avec les
équipages je me souviens très bien à
l'époque parce que les communications
avec la Russie étaient très compliquée
elle est souvent appelé 10 20 fois pour
arriver à avoir la communication mais on
appelait trois ou quatre fois par
semaine la Cité des étoiles pour
discuter avec les équipages
les vols précédents les gens avaient la
possibilité de discuter avec eux une
fois tous les deux ou trois mois donc 92
ça ouvre une nouvelle ère
car depuis la chute du mur de Berlin en
1989 les coopérations spatiales se sont
améliorées renforcés même entre la
Russie et l'Occident
[Musique]
et cela se confirme avec la mission
Altaïr en 1993
Jean-Pierre Haigneré encore un pilote de
l'Armée de l'Air s'envole à son tour
avec Soyouz toujours en direction de
mire pour poursuivre les expériences
réalisées un an plus tôt par Michel
Tonini
mais il marquera surtout l'histoire lors
de sa deuxième mission perceus en 1999
pour la première fois un Français occupe
le poste d'ingénieur navigant lors du
voyage aller à bord du vaisseau spatial
Soyouz une place jusqu'à lors réservée
aux Russes et qui ne fait que renforcer
son profil de pilote
[Musique]
dans ce musée il y a trois places
l'ingénieur navigant qui participe
pilotage sur use est à gauche là où est
déjà pierre Haigneré lors de son
deuxième vol spatial qui est un siège
avec une responsabilité dans la conduite
du Soyouz en tant que machine le Coran
de bord est au milieu et puis à droite
c'est le cosmolo de passager ispatile
qui veut dire en russe celui qui va
faire des expériences scientifiques à
mort
Jean-Pierre avait vraiment un rôle
opérationnel dans le Soyouz au décollage
donc quelque part les graviers un
échelon on était monté au niveau de
l'équipage russe et on a encadré une
consommation
courte durée car autre grande première
pour un Français Jean-Pierre ignoré va
effectuer cette fois une mission longue
durée plus de 6 mois dans la station Mir
c'est à ce jour encore le français qui
est resté le plus longtemps dans
l'espace
[Musique]
Jean-Pierre a été le recordman de durée
de vol d'un cosmonaute non russe depuis
les Américains ont voulu plus longtemps
mais à l'époque c'était lui qui tenait
le record de durée de vol et donc il a
volé 188 jours on a réalisé en plus une
sortie extra-éculaire pendant cette
mission perceus ça a été pour moi la
mission la plus complète accomplie et et
au niveau coopération un moment très
très fort
deux autres Français auront
l'opportunité de voler également à bord
de la station Mir Léopold et Hartz en
1998 lors de la mission Pégase au cours
de laquelle il reprendra des expériences
grâce notamment au matériel laissé sur
place deux ans plus tôt lors d'un des
vols certainement les plus médiatiques
pour la France
celui de Claudie Haigneré première et
encore unique femme française à ce jour
à être allé dans l'espace le 17 août
1996 elle s'envole de Baïkonour à
l'occasion de la mission Cassiopée
mais il faut plus beau que ce que
j'avais pu imaginer et j'ai vraiment
beaucoup de chance de participer d'une
[Musique]
telle milieu de ce qu'on va faire
pendant ces 15 jours c'est un frère je
vis maintenant on ne sait pas sur terre
ça franchir de la de la gravité alors
que là le facteur de Gravity structure
beaucoup des phénomènes de notre vie
Claudie et muret est la première femme
française à être partie dans l'espace
elle est aussi connue pour avoir été
ministre entre 2002 et 2005
donc j'ai eu la chance de participer à
des programmes ou sous un domaine de la
physiologie de la biologie du
développement avec les oeufs de pleure
d'elle que nous avions emporté que ce
soit dans des domaines de physique c'est
un atout dans la compréhension de
mécanisme très fondamentaux et on a
réalisé une mission qui a été
parfaitement réussie elle était content
avec un programme de vol très très
chargé
un peu trop chargé peut-être mais
Claudie l'a bien réalisé
une mission spatiale c'est aussi
énormément de moments de vie entre les
astronautes de la complicité des
échanges et parfois quelques belles
surprises
et lors de sa mission sur mir claudi
ignoré a découvert un souvenir laissé
trois ans plus tôt par celui qui allait
devenir son mari l'astronaute
Jean-Pierre Haigneré
c'est vrai que mon mari au cours de sa
mission avait laissé à bord de la
station une petite lettre pour moi je
suis allée dans la cabine du commandant
regardez sous la paroi en tissu si la
lettre qu'il m'avait promis était bien
dans dans cette cabine et
j'ai cherché je l'ai pas trouvé et là
d'un seul coup le commandant d'équipage
s'est mis à rire en me disant mais si
elle est là la lettre tout le monde a
gardé depuis trois ans pour toi et il me
l'a sorti il l'avait mis dans un petit
coin ça c'est des petites choses de la
vie
la station Mir a marqué profondément et
à jamais la mémoire des cosmonautes
français comme étant le premier gros
engin spatial réellement habité comme on
vivrait finalement dans une grande
maison
la station mirrirait s'accomplétu d'une
station absolument énorme avec tous ces
modules dans sa complexité
dans sa vétusté aussi parce que c'était
une station qui avait déjà beaucoup de
vies beaucoup d'encombrement
il gardait tout à bord de mer donc il y
avait du bazar partout et ranger en
apesanteur c'est impossible les objets
ont un malin plaisir à s'évader même
ceux qu'on croit avoir attaché et ils
vont se balader un peu partout
[Musique]
de croiser un moniteur de télévision qui
flotte un endroit une montre un stylo et
le problème des vols spatiaux
durant ces années 90 les coopérations
s'organisent aussi avec les États-Unis
tout comme Patrick Baudry d'autres
Français vont décrocher leur billet pour
des missions à bord de la navette
spatiale américaine
l'un des plus emblématiques et
Jean-François clervois ou plutôt Billy
Bob pour ses camarades de mission les
Américains avaient du mal à prononcer
son nom
je fais partie du 14e groupe
d'astronautes étiqueté NASA qui me ouvre
d'ailleurs ce pin's ce pins qui a été
dessiné par les 7 premiers de l'étoffe
des héros les 7 premiers astrots
Américains et qui symbolise
l'appartenance à la communauté des Astro
de professionnels de la NASA destiné a
priori à voler plusieurs fois
[Musique]
lors de cette troisième mission à bord
de Discovery Jean-François clervois
était ingénieur de vol depuis
l'intérieur de la navette il était
chargé de diriger les astronautes qui
intervenaient sur le télescope
moi je pilotais le bras robotique au
bout duquel j'avais installé un
cale-pied et il y a un désastre dans ce
cassante qui a les pieds pris dans le
pied et donc je devais le faire aller du
bas du télescope tout en haut en le
faisant passer bien précisément entre
les deux panneaux solaires qu'on n'avait
pas contracté parce que les panneaux
solaires par expérience on savait que si
on les repliait on pourrait plus jamais
les RE déployer donc sur cette mission
contrairement aux autres les panneaux
solaires restaient déployés c'est
vraiment la mission pour la science je
pense que la fin de ma vie à mes petits
enfants arrière-petits c'est une chose
que de leur dirais c'est vous voyez le
télescope Hubble là j'y étais
[Musique]
cette même année en 1999 un autre
Français embarque sur la navette
spatiale il s'agit de Michel Tonini
7 ans après sa mission sur mire il part
pour 5 jours en tant que spécialiste
avec les Américains mission au cours de
laquelle un autre télescope spatial est
déployé
Chandra un télescope à rayon X
la navette a aussi accueilli trois ans
plus tôt en 1996 le premier scientifique
français à être parti dans l'espace
tout comme Claudie Haigneré médecin la
même année sur mire Jean-Jacques Favier
physicien et le symbole de l'ouverture
en France du métier d'astronaute a de
nouveaux profils autres que militaires
le 20 juin 1986 il réalise une mission
de 17 jours au cours de laquelle il a
notamment fait l'objet d'expérience
parfois invasive en physiologie humaine
[Musique]
résultat
sans précédent par l'intensité et la
qualité des mesures et c'est ce qui
démontre l'intérêt d'avoir
désastronautes à bord de ses
laboratoires et des astronautes ayant
une formation scientifique dans le
domaine concerné
à travers les agences spatiales
françaises européennes américaines
canadienne et italienne se sont 10 pays
qui travaillent ensemble et qui
mobilisent leurs chercheurs sur cette
mission elle est un très bel exemple de
la coopération internationale et des
partenariats scientifiques qui
s'instaure durant ces années
les Etats-Unis se rapprochent même de la
Russie dans cette période dans le cadre
d'un nouveau projet de station spatiale
c'est ainsi que l'on verra une navette
américaine arrivée à la station russe
Mir symbole historique très fort d'un
rapprochement entre les deux grandes
puissances
et donc ils sont venus me voir les
américains ils nous ont observé et je
pense qu'on était assez jalousé de
pouvoir travailler aussi facilement avec
les Russes
[Musique]
comment tisser des liens de confiance le
CNES la France est vu aujourd'hui dans
le monde dans le corps et au-delà du vol
habité c'est vrai aussi sur le vol
habité comme un pays vraiment de la
coopération internationale
en mars 2001 après 15 ans d'exploitation
et de succès la station russe Mir
vieillissante abîmée fait l'objet d'une
désorbitation contrôlée
mais une autre station spatiale est déjà
opérationnelle l'ISF un projet piloté
depuis quelques années par les
Américains développer conjointement avec
les Russes avec la participation
également des agences spatiales
européennes japonaises et canadiennes
cette structure est aujourd'hui le plus
grand objet artificiel placé en orbite
autour de la Terre aussi grand qu'un
terrain de football
l'ISS est en permanence occupé depuis le
début des années 2000 par des
astronautes qui consacrent ici encore
leur temps à la recherche scientifique
[Musique]
et le premier français à s'être rendu à
bord de l'ISS est une Française 5 ans
après son premier vol sur mir Claudie
Haigneré repart de Baïkonour le 21
octobre 2001 pour la mission Andromède
où elle est ingénieur de bord
durant 9 jours claudieignerait a réalisé
à bord de l'ISS un programme
expérimental sur l'observation de la
Terre l'atmosphère les sciences de la
vie et de la matière il y SS va
continuer de grandir grâce notamment à
la participation de deux autres Français
tout d'abord Philippe Perrin en juin
2002 il participe à un important
programme d'assemblage d'éléments de la
station et pour cela il réalise en 13
jours trois sorties extravéculaires il
passe plus de 19 heures en scaphandre
dans le vide spatial
[Musique]
autre étape majeure dans l'histoire de
la Station spatiale internationale en
2008 le français Léopold deshars lors de
sa seconde mission va profondément
participer à en créer la place visible
de l'Europe au sein même de l'ISF
il s'envole le 7 février pour 48 jours
la navette qui le transporte vers la
station qu'on voit un nouveau module il
s'agit de Columbus un laboratoire
scientifique de l'Agence spatiale
européenne
Léopold deshars et celui qui a été en
charge entre autres de piloter le bras
robotique qui a amené Columbus
sur le port d'attache de la Station
spatiale internationale il est resté
cette semaine donc c'est aussi le
deuxième vol le plus long d'un français
dans l'espace
l'astronaute français participe au
manoeuvre de raccordement Léopold et
Hartz fixe définitivement Columbus à
l'ISS c'est la première fois qu'un
module européen reste en permanence dans
l'espace
me
parce que pour moi c'est vraiment le
début en fait d'une d'un espace très
très européen un peu moins national
franco-français comme c'était le cas
avant
Thomas Pesquet est le prochain français
à partir dans l'espace pilote de ligne
ingénieur il rêve de poser le pied là où
personne n'est encore allée tout d'un
coup
les Russes l'Agence spatiale européenne
et ça c'était fait par un Français et
puis on venait mettre tout ça en commun
et puis c'était le début de quelque
chose on savait que c'était le début de
d'une nouvelle ère qui moi m'a marqué
peut-être plus que d'autres vols
auparavant
l'émission spatiale fascine entre 1982
et 2008 neuf Français sont partis dans
l'espace au cours de 17 missions menées
en collaboration avec les Russes et les
Américains il ne cesse de partager leur
expérience suscitant de nombreuses
vocations mais les sélections
d'astronautes sont rares et extrêmement
exigeante elle reste néanmoins ouverte à
tous
dernier en date celle de 2009 réalisée
par l'Agence spatiale européenne à
l'issue de tests psychologique médicaux
et professionnel le jeune Français
Thomas Pesquet a 31 ans a été retenu
avec 5 autres Européens parmi plus de
8000 candidatures
[Musique]
lycées
à une mission et relever ainsi les défis
spatiaux de demain si tout se passe
comme prévu il rejoindra fin 2016 la
Station spatiale internationale pour une
durée de 6 mois
moi j'aime bien dire que ce métier je le
fais pour moi ça me fait rêver moi
d'aller dans l'espace que je voulais
faire quand j'étais petit mais on le
fait aussi pour les gens je voulais que
ça serve à quelque chose pas juste à
m'enrichir dans mon coin et puis être
content avec ma petite vie je l'ai que
c'est un côté un peu utile donc
astronaute c'est le métier de rêve parce
qu'il y a les deux là dedans
Thomas Pesquet s'entraîne au quotidien
pour sa mission auprès des agences
partenaires de la Station spatiale
internationale en Allemagne au centre
des astronautes européens mais aussi à
la NASA à Houston en Russie à la Cité
des étoiles ou encore au Japon et au
Canada
le but c'est de se qualifier sur tous
les systèmes qu'on va utiliser sur une
mission spatiale apprendre la station
spatiale pour se qualifier sur chacun
des modules bras robotiques à piloter
système de scaphandre américain système
de scaphandre russe apprend les
expériences scientifiques à prendre le
russe pour pouvoir communiquer faire du
sport ça consiste un peu tout ça mon
quotidien donc heureusement les jours se
ressemblent pas mais ils sont en général
bien occupés Thomas Pesquier doit
également apprendre le Soyouz qui est à
ce jour le seul système encore
opérationnel pour envoyer des hommes
dans l'espace
car le programme de navette américaine
bien que majestueuse avec ses coups de
lancement prohibitifs associés aux
terribles accidents de challenger et
Columbia a été définitivement arrêté en
juillet 2011
Thomas Pesquet répète donc
inlassablement les procédures pour parer
à toute éventualité une fois dans
l'espace il faut prévoir et savoir gérer
l'imprévu
dans une piscine géante qui accueille
l'immensité de l'ISF la pesanteur et
même simulée pour préparer les sorties
extravéculaires
vous pouvez imaginer ce qu'affront de
200 kg on est mis à l'eau par une grue
la journée commence comme ça à 6h30 du
matin et là on est comme si on flottait
dans la station donc on est avec notre
scaphandre 200 kg c'est pressurisé donc
on est à l'intérieur d'un pneu gonflé en
fait tout bêtement qui résiste à nos
mouvements donc physiquement c'est un
peu difficile on a toujours en train de
se battre contre le scaphandre quand on
sort on a des Bleus partout est-ce que
c'est structures métalliques qui sont
faites pour être souples autant que
possible mais qui quand même a tendance
à s'opposer au mouvement des gros gants
malhabiles c'est comme écraser une balle
de tennis chaque fois qu'on veut serrer
un outil et puis aller visser un boulon
ou faire des choses comme ça c'est une
des parties les plus physiques de
l'entraînement d'astronaute
comme ces prédécesseurs Thomas Pesquet
complète sa formation sur des vols dit
zéro g pour zéro gravité qui s'effectue
aujourd'hui en France au départ de
Bordeaux grâce à une technique de
pilotage particulière sur des avions de
ligne spécialement aménagés il peut
ainsi vivre le phénomène de la pesanteur
sans avoir besoin d'être placé en orbite
l'appareil qui évolue dans des altitudes
traditionnelles entre 6 et 9000 mètres
d'altitude réalise des séries de montées
et de descentes que l'on appelle
parabole durant des périodes de 22
secondes les effets de la gravité sont
annulés
pendant les derniers mois de préparation
Thomas Pesquet va passer la plus grande
partie de son temps à répéter les
expériences qu'il va exécuter dans ce
gigantesque laboratoire qui est la
Station spatiale internationale son
séjour de 6 mois sera entièrement
planifié pour lui permettre d'accomplir
toutes ces missions 50% de son temps
sera dédié à réaliser des expériences
scientifiques les 50% restants seront
consacrés à la logistique la maintenance
et à la réparation
est un garçon pour lequel j'ai eu
beaucoup
d'admiration je le trouve formidable
parce qu'il est plein de convictions
d'engagement il traduit complètement
cette jeunesse aujourd'hui optimiste
désireuse de portée des actions fortes
beaucoup de simplicité beaucoup
d'humilité de charisme et d'envie de
partager c'est ça aussi un astronaute
les astronautes sont les explorateurs
d'un territoire qu'ils ouvrent peu à peu
au plus grand nombre
l'orbite basse terrestre est désormais
maîtrisée avec une présence humaine
ininterrompue à bord de l'ISF même si
l'étape de la colonisation spatiale
n'est pas encore d'actualité entre 2001
et 2009 7 touristes de l'espace ont
déboursé jusqu'à 35 millions de dollars
pour rejoindre la station spatiale
internationale
j'ai eu la chance de vivre à
l'entraînement à la Cité des étoiles
avec ces quelques milliardaires qui ont
eu la possibilité de s'acheter un vol à
bord de la session c'était des gens qui
réalisaient leurs rêves et qu'il
réalisait au quotidien ils ont vécu
chacun des instants de la préparation de
la mission de la mission elle-même et
qu'on puisse rendre ce rêve accessible à
certains c'est bien il faut pas faire
miroiter le fait que
on pourra aller dans l'espace
immédiatement comment je souhaite mais
que ça soit ouvert à quelques-uns oui
allez dans l'espace c'est vraiment un
privilège immense c'est pour ça que je
suis un fervent défenseur du tourisme
spatial sur le plan humain je pense que
ce dont un homme peut rêver depuis de
plus grand de plus extraordinaire c'est
vraiment d'avoir cette possibilité de
regarder sa planète de cette manière
le tourisme spatial est sur le point de
se démocratiser non pas à bord de l'ISS
mais sur des engins privés pour des vols
où chacun pourra vivre pendant quelques
minutes la pesanteur
parmi les projets réalistes envisagés un
avion fusé européen
issu de la réflexion d'ingénieurs
français allemand anglais et espagnol
avaient notamment été présenté en 2007
par un acteur majeur de l'industrie
aérospatiale en France
ces vols disent subordo doivent
développer suffisamment d'énergie pour
atteindre les 100 km d'altitude et faire
vivre pleinement pendant quelques
instants les mêmes sensations qu'un
astronautes
pendant 4 minutes on est dans
l'environnement spatial que j'ai connu
le ciel noir la pesanteur une vue de la
terre hallucinante et puis un gros coup
de pied aux fesses au décollage qui vous
fait sentir viril pendant quelques
minutes ça on va le connaître
probablement avant la fin de la décennie
avant 2020
difficile aujourd'hui d'entrevoir ce que
sera le futur de la conquête de l'espace
pour les astronautes professionnels ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'elle se fera pour
la France et les autres pays membres de
l'Agence spatiale européenne comme elle
a commencé pour les Français dans une
coopération internationale avec les
grandes puissances spatiales
d'aujourd'hui et celle de demain mais
déjà chacun rêve d'aller plus loin de
quitter l'orbite basse et de dépasser à
nouveau les frontières de la terre
dans les années 2020 on connaîtra
probablement les premiers vols
lointains de longue durée qui
retourneront à des distances au moins
égales à celle de la lune moi ce qui
m'intéresse dans le vol spatial c'est de
m'inscrire
sur une trajectoire c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui m'intéresse dans
le vol spatial habité c'est qu'il fasse
quelque chose de nouveau on en revient
donc à cette planète Mars qu'on souhaite
et qu'on va sans doute explorer dans les
50 ans qui viennent de fortes chances
alors le problème c'est la possibilité
de se déplacer à grande vitesse dans
l'univers et pour l'instant on est on
est très [__]
allez poser le pied ailleurs là où
personne est encore allé sera sans doute
l'un des grands enjeux des vols habités
de demain mars situé à plus de 200
millions de kilomètres de la Terre reste
la planète la plus proche la plus facile
à atteindre mais les technologies
actuelles ne permettent pourtant pas
encore de la rejoindre raisonnablement
en moins de 200 jours
j'aimerais bien de mon vivant voir le
vaisseau parce que le vaisseau qui
partira vers Mars il a rien à voir avec
ce qu'on a connu jusqu'à ce jour c'est
un vaisseau où il faudra qu'il y ait une
autonomie totale où il faudra pouvoir se
réfugier en cas d'éruption solaire pour
pas se faire irradier mortellement par
les protons envoyés par le soleil donc
on aura vraiment franchi un bon
astronautique quand on sera prêt à
envoyer des gens vers Mars et j'aimerais
le livre si on y va de toute façon et on
ira ce sera en coopération
internationale donc on peut pas dire
l'Europe ou telle nation ira planter son
drapeau parce que toute façon il y aura
un Américain un Russe un Européen un
chinois donc il va falloir tirer la
Courtepaille pour savoir quel drapeau on
plante ce sera je pense un grand pas
pour l'homme en général pour de vrai
cette fois-ci pas juste une nation un
peu pour tout le monde en attendant que
la technologie évolue encore pour
conquérir de nouveaux territoires
l'homme sait qu'il peut d'ores et déjà
compter sur ces machines ces sondes
spatiales ces robots pour démarrer le
défrichage d'autres planètes
d'autres lunes d'autres corps célestes
aujourd'hui il doit se contenter d'une
réalité qui n'était pourtant encore
aussi qu'une fiction du temps des
premières missions spatiales
la France avec ses 9 astronautes déjà
partie dans l'espace et leur 17 vols
habités même si cela semble bien loin
des centaines de voyages spatiaux
effectués par les Russes et les
Américains se place pourtant tout juste
derrière les deux superpuissances
depuis le temps des premiers Français
dans l'espace Jean-Loup Chrétien Patrick
Baudry la France a toujours été un
partenaire de choix dont la
concrétisation de ces missions
et un dixième français se prépare à son
tour à sortir de l'atmosphère terrestre
pour une durée de 6 mois
au-delà de sa mission à bord de l'ISF il
portera en lui l'histoire d'une
tradition de succès français
histoire de la conquête spatiale
continue
[Musique]